welcome back to Las Vegas now United Way
of Southern Nevada the sponsors of this
segment are ready to give their 2023
Community impact grants and the
organization's president and CEO Julian
high is here to tell us more we've just
been sitting here chatting because you
are a Vegas local and I'm so thrilled to
meet to meet Reggie Diaz's daughter I
mean it's like the highlight of my month
maybe my year yes I'm completely serious
so nice to meet you I appreciate that
this has been a pleasure
um now you know we were talking about
your organization basically you're a
non-profit that supports other
non-profits which is great explain what
you guys do that's a great um uh 10
second elevator pitch
it's great very very astute in terms of
what we do we we're the leading convener
collaborator and and spokes advocacy
Organization for non-profits in this
community there are lots of really
wonderful organizations in town we do
lots of really wonderful things and all
different kinds of areas and United Way
of Southern Nevada is the one
organization and that is tasked with and
responds to being a voice for every
segment of the nonprofit sector that's
so great that's amazing
this is really important for these
organizations what's the process and how
does that work so this year we are we
are privileged and lucky enough to be
able to fund 1.5 million dollars and
donor fund it dollars that means that's
money that we have gone out into the
community and raised either from from
this community or through grants or
other philanthropic Endeavors and we get
to
distribute those funds to other 501c3
organizations who go through a pretty
rigorous Grant proposal process right
and we have a group of really engaged
and really passionate people who serve
on the Review Committee pretty rigorous
process that we go through and they um
and they then determine who are going to
be the recipients of those grants and
and the funding amounts okay and then
you know this is a rigorous process
because you guys have to Choose Wisely
where you put your where you put your
money me give us an example of who are
the types of organizations I'll give you
an example of one organization that a
lot of people in the community may know
today it's called leaders in training
which is one of my um it's one of the
great examples of what happens when an
individual puts himself out and wants to
really make a change and have impact in
the community and in that nonprofit the
founder who's now A Nevada assembly
woman put forth her 2 500 of her own
money many many years ago to start
leaders in training and they're one of
the our biggest
Grant receivers in the last cycle that's
incredible I have to interrupt you we
have 15 seconds but I want to tell
everybody who's watching that's
interested you know when is the
application due March 10th by 5 PM
Pacific Standard time there you go there
we go great thank you so much for all
the work that United Way does for our
community thank you it's been a pleasure
pleasure meeting you now thank you again
to the United Way of Southern Nevada for
sponsoring this segment call
702-892-2300 or visit
uwsn.org funding good luck